we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p i received a
lot of emails and comments and tweets
about the Brett Kavanaugh situation and
now that as I talk to you about at the
top of the show it actually is slightly
more likely that there could be
significant delays if not an
interruption to the confirmation of
Brett Kavanaugh to the Supreme Court as
Donald Trump would very much like to see
the question is increasingly coming up
of okay well then what happens and
that's the subject of today's voicemail
take a listen
I did it okay what outcomes you see as
possible with Democrats trust week block
Cavanaugh assuming any nomination
can be bought coming to terms come on
Democrats win will we not just pick up
with it others possibly work
conservative gauge thank yes we probably
will and that's that's the reality so
listen it there's no sense in
sugarcoating political realities more
than likely if Donald Trump were to be
removed from office however it happens
more than likely unless Mike Pence is
specifically implicated in in that
removal in the grounds for that removal
which he could be remember Paul Manafort
now indicted and pleading guilty and
being found guilty of all sorts of stuff
was involved in the selection of Mike
Pence and we don't know how deep it
might go more than likely you replace
Trump with pence and it's a absolute and
total disaster and potentially Pence is
even more effective at getting stuff
done
likewise if it is possible to delay the
confirmation of Brett Kavanaugh through
the midterms you debt then need
Democrats to win and take over the
Senate and it's not the most likely
scenario depending on which estimates
you look at there's somewhere between a
twenty and forty eight looking
optimistically percent chance that
Democrats take over the Senate still
could happen it either will happen or it
won't but it's not the most likely
scenario
in either case whether or not this goes
through the midterms and whether or not
Democrats do or don't take over the
Senate more than likely Trump would just
put up someone else
maybe being more careful about their
scandals and we've already seen that
Democrats aren't going to hold up the
nomination merely because they feel that
Merrick garland should have been
confirmed under President Obama I agree
with them that that's what should have
happened ultimately Democrats have not
shown a willingness to actually put
their feet down and say it doesn't
matter who you nominate we will obstruct
at every opportunity we will try to
prevent this from getting out of
committee because it should have been
Merrick garland and in the end if they
don't take over the Senate it's not
going to matter so this is why my
overwhelming belief is that it doesn't
even really matter in the end more than
a symbolic victory if it doesn't end up
being Cavanagh because it will be
someone else unless very specific
situations sort of happen and and
circumstances come to fruition but
that's not a reason to just say do
whatever you want and I'm glad that at
least there's an attempt being made to
put some roadblocks here or there should
be many more on today's bonus show Laura
Ingram's brother is waging a war against
her if you haven't been following that
story it's quite interesting scientists
have also identified four personality
types we will talk about them and Elon
Musk is now being sued by that tie cave
diver over defamation for the pedo guy
pedophile guy tweet all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show two ways
to get access to the bonus show first of
all become a member at WWJ pakman.com
coupon code available it's vote soon 18
and it'll save you 40% other option
become a $5 a month or more patreon
contributor at patreon.com slash david
pakman show if that does it for me
I will talk to you on the bonus show
very very soon